benoît hamon va parler de l'actualité
avec vous mais d'abord ça faisait
longtemps qu'on ne vous avait pas vu
benoît hamon qu'est-ce que vous devenez
côté j'ai créé des libres mais pas que
ou un livre en tout cas je bats je me
suis reconverti dans le secteur privé
avec ma société je travaille sur
l'amélioration des bonnes pratiques dans
les entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
les coopératives les associations les
mutuelles c'est aujourd'hui le travail
qui m'occupe dans la journée mais au jeu
très de télétravail comme beaucoup on a
là en plus de l'écriture de ce livre
dont on a parlé mais d'abord on va
parler de la crise sanitaire
oui alors nous reprenons progressivement
le contrôle de l'épidémie a dit olivier
vers en le confinant c'est la bonne
solution pour vous c'était la seule pour
faire reculer l'épidémie il y avait une
autre y avait esquivé une alternative
côté j'ai envie de vous dire que je ne
sais pas vraiment s'il y avait des
alternatives je pense que l'europe si un
reproche que je ferais au gouvernement
c'est peut-être de ne pas avoir assez
anticipé sur cette deuxième vague de
confinement et je pense notamment dans
l'éducation nationale où finalement on
paye sans doute aujourd'hui trois années
où à force de ne pas ouvrir de postes
aux concours
on se retrouve avec une pénurie de
personnels qui auraient pu faire face en
dédoublant les classes un peu partout
dans les lycées dans les collèges
y'aura ni il y aura pu avoir
d'autres choix de fait mais
objectivement aujourd'hui je vais pas me
jeter dans les polémiques qui existe
entre la bonne solution de monsieur
untel ou la bonne solution de madame
untel docteur ceci professeur cela moi
je suis passé par la magie d'une colline
on sait même pas ça c'est que je crois
que tout ça ça mais surtout du désordre
dans la tête de beaucoup de français
qu'on en vient contester la science
qu'on en vient à contester tout et
n'importe quoi donc
écoutez moi je je je vois que le
confinement il fait mal des gens en
particulier notamment toutes les
entreprises qui sont obligés de mettre
la clé sous la porte ou de faire des
plans sociaux
tous les salariés qui parce que le
chômage partiel ne suffit pas ou parce
qu'ils n'y ont pas accès je veux dire
perdre leur travail
il ya un million de pauvres en plus 10
millions en france ça je pense qu'on
doit en parler
et si finalement moi j'avais envie de
parler d'une chose aujourd'hui c'est pas
de rajouter ma voix une cacophonie dans
laquelle à mon avis plus personne
n'entend grand chose mais c'est de dire
la priorité absolue c'est de résorber la
pauvreté dans ce pays à 10 millions de
pauvres hères que c'est l'équivalent de
la population totale de la suède ou du
portugal
je veux dire on en est là aujourd'hui en
france
ce devrait être le la une de tous les
journaux télévisés ce devrait être
l'obsession des responsables politiques
et pour commencer alors peut-être qu'on
en parlera mai mais puisqu'on en enjeu
la sénatrice qui était là juste avant
moi évoquer la question des minima
sociaux il ya une mesure très simple à
faire
l'automatisation des minima sociaux en
france pour avoir le droit au rsa faut
le demander et on sait que par 2 to fall
demandé à 30 % de gens qui ne l'ont pas
c'est aussi simple que ça si on ne
change pas c'est pourquoi c'est parce
que l'état
merci monsieur le maire donc sait
pertinemment qu on fait des économies en
gardant ce système là c'est ça qui nous
ont fait d hab
je pense qu'il y avait il y avait quand
même un projet d'instaurer un revenu
universel à elle et rue à l'euro ni de
revenu universel activité c'est à dire
d'automatiser l'essentiel les
prestations
toujours en course à d'ailleurs le côté
épique du président de la république ça
pardon de le dire mais c'est l'idée non
mais je je je dis ça avec un clin d'oeil
mais prenez une belle idée le revenu
universel et ajouter un mot activité est
en fait en faire il a il a détourné
votre hymne aux métis au rsa appauvri
puisque ce qu'il proposait était ni plus
ni moins que le rsa tel qu'il est mais
avec des obligations supplémentaires ces
terres quand on mettait encore plus de
pression et de fardeau sur les pauvres
ils sont 10 millions dans ce pays et je
le redis les 18 25 ans n'ont pas le
droit au rsa c'est une un anachronisme
en europe
y a qu'en france qu'on décide que les
jeunes doivent êtes pauvre que c'est
bien il faut que stan le cuir comme
après tout tu sois pas assister dès le
début c'est délirant ils ont le droit de
voter mais ils n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir le minimum social auquel ont
droit tous les autres ce qui est ignoré
la difficulté de trouver du travail
aujourd'hui la difficulté de vivre
correctement de son premier salaire
d'avoir un logement donc on est vraiment
dans dans la lah le fait de donner des
coups de poing à l'estomac la jeunesse
de ce pays
d'une part il faudrait donc l'étendre
aux 18 25 ans et de l'automatiser c'est
c'est inadmissible qu'on demande aux
plus pauvres
aujourd'hui de remplir un dossier pour
avoir le droit au rsa
tout ça pour faire des économies je veux
dire à bruno le maire je dis à jean
castex je dirais manuel macron il ya 10
millions de pauvres la mesure immédiate
à prendre c'est l'automatisation du des
minima sociaux et du rsa et là on ferait
me semble-t-il ça coûterait quoi
probablement 3,4 milliards de plus
aujourd'hui je crois que le rsa doit
coûter 11 milliards d'euros
donc on si on fait à peu près 30%
d'économie il faut rajouter 4 milliards
mais mais c'est l'urgence absolue que de
le voir vous leur dites par notre
intermédiaire là ce matin sur ce plateau
où vous être adressé directement à eux
pour ce à plusieurs reprises et si c'est
le cas
est-ce qui vous écoute non alors moi je
suis d'abord retiré de la politique
active je vous remercie de ma vie tes
propos pour ce livre mais je ne suis
plus au contact de toutes ces de tous
ces dirigeants politiques un peu plus
les gens de gauche que je connais mais
même avec eux je je ne leur parle que de
manière très épisodique dès les
élections présidentielles je défendrai
le principe de l'automatisation je
trouvé choquant ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est qu'il faille remplir un
dossier toutes les associations qui sont
aujourd'hui sur le front la fondation
abbé pierre le secours catholique le
secours populaire tous le demande tout
le monde ça n'a pas été fait au
précédent gouvernement davantage vos
soyons parfaitement honnête mais avant
il ya 1,6 mais s'il ya bien un moment où
votre message à toutes ses chances de
toutes les chances de passer c'est
maintenant non oui mais j'espère qu'il
va au tout cas sur la question de la
transformation qui me semble nécessaire
de notre rapport au travail ce que le
revenu universel que je propose c'est un
revenu universel pour tout le monde ça
viendrait compléter votre salaire tous
les deux ça viendrait remplacer une
partie des minima sociaux
c'est donc les retraités le percevraient
donc là on est aux à un changement
radical qui a me semble-t-il la portée
de ce qu'avait été la création de la
sécurité sociale c'est arrive un moment
où il faut poser des actes qui permet de
réconcilier le pays et on aurait
conciliera pas le pays en dehors de la
question sociale et lui vaut des mesures
universelles aussi parce que l'on nous
avons besoin du consentement à l'impôt
des plus riches pour financer les
mécanismes solides a été si des mesures
ne sont pas universels on finira par
n'avoir que deux pauvres droits réservés
aux plus pauvres
et ça ce n'est pas le modèle social
français du coup évidemment vous êtes
plus que jamais le champ train de ce
revenu universel dans ce livre alors y'a
pas que le gouvernement qui est pas
forcément convaincu par ce revenu
universel il y avait aussi une partie
des français notamment une partie de
votre camp lors de la présidentielle
qu'est ce que vous leur dites
aujourd'hui pour les convaincre que pour
vous c'est la bonne solution c'est voir
la seule solution dans l'époque convives
côté d'abord j'ai le sentiment qu'on a
tous un peu fait l'expérience au tout
cas beaucoup de français du fait que le
travail se résume pas à l'emploi
aujourd'hui quand vous dites vous un
travail en fait vous entendez avez vous
un emploi pour autant celui qui n'a pas
de travail en théorie pas d'emploi
travail quand même il chez lui il
travaille en étant bénévole dans une
association
il travaille comme un consommateur
travaillent gratuitement désormais parce
que sans vous en rendre compte
quand vous appris mais vous même votre
billet de train quand vous loguez sur
une machine à l'aéroport quand vous
allez à une caisse automatique vous
remplacer des employés c'est à dire que
des entreprises vous faut travailler
mais gratuitement
je crois d'abord qu'il faut reconnaître
que le travail ça n'est plus ce que
c'était avant
déjà dans l'emploi les carrières ne sont
plus linéaires mais en plus on travaille
de plus en plus sans être rémunérés pour
ce travail première chose la deuxième
chose je crois que c'est l'idée la plus
une des deux idées les plus centrales de
ce livre c'est le japon on oublie que
quand on arrive sur terre quand on est
on est riche d'un héritage collectif qui
est celui de nos ancêtres et rien ne
justifie que cet héritage là cette
richesse qui est créée grâce à terry
héritage qui n'est pas dû à notre
activité
mais à cela leur ceux qui sont passés
avant nous rien ne justifie qu'elle soit
accaparée par une minorité et le revenu
universel vient comme un instrument de
prêt distribution de la richesse et
c'est cette révolution là alors où ce
changement civilisationnel là que je
pense qu'il faut introduire plus le fait
et je crois que ça ça doit parler aux
syndicalistes doit parler aux femmes et
aux hommes de gauche ou à toutes celles
et ceux y compris à droite qui sont
attachés à la peau partage de la
richesse c'est que aujourd'hui les
salariés comptent ils n'ont d'autre
choix que de prendre un emploi difficile
un métier pénible et un petit salaire
pour vivre
si le revenu universel s'ajouter à ce
petit salaire il redécouvrirait une
autonomie une pratique de la liberté et
une capacité à négocier et à choisir
qu'ils n'ont pas c'est donc un outil
d'émancipation et démocratique
et c'est pour ça que je crois que je
vais le dire à la gauche et j'espère
qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle reprendra simple
de ses idées aujourd'hui la gauche est
là en panne de stratégie au moment de
dire comment on redistribue la richesse
on va augmenter les salaires lesquels
quand vous faites pour augmenter les
salaires dans le privé
par quels moyens il ya une panne de
stratégie
elle aimerait bien trouver la solution
mais elle n'a pas je pense que le revenu
universel est l'instrument par laquelle
on redonne de l'autonomie aux individus
et donc de la capacité à distribuer
aussi de la richesse en redistribuant le
pouvoir il ya une initiative
intéressante du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée qui veut préparer un projet
de loi sur un revenu de base et une
dotation universelle elle le fait avec
l'association pas fait la structure
parlement et citoyens en proposant à
tout un chacun de participer à
l'élaboration de ce projet de loi est ce
que vous avez suivi ce projet est ce que
vous y participez vous non pas à titre
personnel mais je trouve bien que qu'une
partie des idées que j'ai défendue
chemine dans le livre que je défende
toutes ces notions de dotation universel
moi je parle de ce qu'on appelle le
capital d'émancipation appartement où le
revenu universel et versé de la
naissance à la mort son montant n'est
pas le même de 0 à 18 ans et on peut
imaginer que si chaque enfant recevait
de 0 à 18 ans 300 euros par mois
200 euros irait aux parents en
remplacement des allocations familiales
lors ce qui permettrait déjà de financer
cette fraction du revenu universel et
100 euros serait timo par mois serait
immobilisé sur un compte disponibles aux
18 ans de chaque jeune français de façon
à ce qu'ils disposent d'un capital
d'émancipation le moyen de pouvoir
justement se projeter sans être comme
aujourd'hui privés d'à peu près tout
jeter comme ça dans le vide alors on va
dire ah oui c'est normal
qui est que ce soit ainsi mais moi je ne
pense pas je pense que dans une société
qui est de plus en plus violents de plus
en plus inégalitaire de plus en plus dur
au moment où les générations précédentes
laissent aussi un pays par non mais mais
blessé écologiquement avec des blessures
qui est une blessure pour partie
irréversible il est temps peut-être de
regarder les choses un peu différemment
et de donner à notre jeunesse qui est
très créative les moyens de sa propre
émancipation et de tracer son chemin
pour corriger réparer ça tombe des
erreurs qui ont été commises par les
générations ses parents et grands
parents sur le principe de participer à
l'élaboration de la loi avec d'autres
citoyens je trouve ça formidable
socialement je trouve que la
coproduction elle est utile mais ici
avec nous tous les groupes qui veulent
travailler à ces idées là moi je me
réjouis que que c'est ce principe existe
plus on associera les citoyens aux
décisions qui les concernent
mieux ce sera maintenant aujourd'hui
j'observe que ce sont plutôt des
citoyens spécialistes qui s'impliquent
dans ses processus là pourra trouver les
formes pour pour finalement démocratiser
ces processus errements sur l'écologie
dont il est aussi question d'un vote qui
vous dit le revenu universel et aussi la
jambe social indispensable à la
transition écologique qu'il faut engager
d'urgence comment vous lier les deux
dossiers
écoutez moi pendant l'élection
présidentielle j'avais dit je ne serai
plus socialistes et écologistes et c'est
parce que aujourd'hui on peut plus être
socialiste et écologiste m'envoyer
l'inversé vrai également c'est à dire je
crois qu'on ne peut pas être écologiste
si on ne se préoccupe pas de la façon
dont résorber les inégalités sociales
moi je suis très heureux de du coup
repris par les deux
europe ecologie les verts avec julien
bayou qui a décidé d'embrasser et la
question écologique et la question
sociale est d'articuler l'une à l'autre
en permanence non non non non dans sa
prise de parole je crois que c'est un
aussi un message extrêmement fort alors
en quoi le revenu universel changerait
cela et c'est quelqu'un qu'on bat
d'ailleurs que je partage avec julien
bayou qui avait porté cette
expérimentation à paris et qui a été un
des premiers aussi à défendre cette idée
là mais en quoi cela change-t-il si
aujourd'hui vous avez un petit salaire
que vous êtes comme en ile de france
une mère célibataire 25 % des ménages en
île de france par exemple ce sont des
mamans seules avec des enfants que vous
n'avez qu'un petit salaire et que vous
voulez quand même garantir à vos enfants
qu'ils aient les mêmes jouets la même
alimentation la même pâte à tartiner
bref et bien vous allez faire quoi comme
choix bah vous n'en avez pas vous allez
choisir les aliments les vêtements les
biens électroménagers low cost terre des
produits fabriqués dans des conditions
dégueulasse a au prix de d'inégalités
sociales abominable d'une exploitation
de travailleurs très très loin avec un
coût écologique pour les transporter ici
et une durée de vie qui est très faible
et un coût écologique énorme et bien le
revenu universel il change quoi c'est
qu'il vous donne le choix il vous donne
la possibilité et bien de basculer vers
le bio de basculer vers des biens plus
dur à peut-être plus cher mais qui
correspondent aussi bas à votre droit de
pouvoir alimenter vêtir équipe et votre
famille et vos enfants avec des biens de
qualité qui n'ont pas de mauvaises
conséquences pour leur santé
et c'est en ce sens que le revenu
universel change les choses il permettra
aussi la formation du juste prix c'est
quoi le juste prix c'est que quand vous
achetez un verre jeunes sous louent ou
achètent pas un plat de 2 ou un kouign
amann mais bon le savoir est la
démonstration va pas marcher que le
kouign amann ou un plat de un plat
préparé le juste prix c'est celui qui
permet que celui qui a produit cela
l'agriculteur le transformateur
l'ouvrier soient payés correctement pour
le travail qu'il a fait est qu'en plus
on est respecté l'environnement
c'est ça le juste prix c'est bien le
revenu universel il va donner à tous ces
français le choix de pouvoir arbitrer en
faveur de ces produits là et de ne pas
être condamnée à acheter des produits de
mauvaise qualité
c'est donc un instrument me semble-t-il
de la transition écologique et tout ça
c'est bien sûr à lire dans votre livre
benoît hamon ce qu'il faut de courage on
va parler de quelques qu'on peut prendre
place des libraires c'est les
indépendants si je préfère qu'on achète
sur place des libraires ses terres le
toqué renault
ça vous voyez nommé justement amazonia
plusieurs élus élus ong syndicalistes
qui ont signé une tribune hier pour
demander la limitation de l'expansion
d'amazon je crois que vous n'êtes pas
dans la liste des signataires je vous ai
pas bien je suis non mais parce que je
vous dis je ne suis plus dans la vie
politique active moi je je je
alors là il n'y a pas que des polypes
non mais moi je pense qu'il a raison
aujourd'hui de dire que ce modèle-là du
commerce en ligne ce qui est tellement
simple ont cliqué et ça nous arrive
c'est un modèle qui en train de détruire
nos le milieu dans lequel on vit
commerces de proximité disparaît et en
détruisant semble d'être quoi les
interactions sociales trouvé qu'on se
voie trop qu'on se parle trop qu'on se
touche tron ont de moins en moins on est
arrivé à nos écrans on est on passe on a
des filtres en permanence entre les
individus moi je pense que tous ceux qui
nous remet en situation de faire société
est bon et je pense que donc il faut
effectivement limiter non seulement le
comédien l'omniprésence de ces modèles
là dans nos vies mais aussi leur
puissance et parce qu'il dérégule le
reste comme a polling les grandes
surfaces avaient commencé à déréguler le
commerce
maintenant le coup l'estocade est en
quelque sorte est portée par le commerce
en ligne
donc je pense oui qu'il faut vous n'est
pas signé mais vous êtes d'accord
oui voilà je suis d'accord avec le fait
on va parler d'actualité on voulait
évoquer voilà d'autres sujets avec vous
notamment l'école jean michel blanquer a
annoncé des augmentations dès le mois de
mai en fait pour un tiers des
professeurs 100 euros net par mois
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
au-dessus de ce type de geste est à la
hauteur de 2 du malaise je pense qu'ils
sont nécessaires pour commencer je pense
à ce que l'on dit ou pas je pense qu'il
faut revaloriser la carrière des
enseignants de manière très importante
il faut la revaloriser dès l'entrée
après les concours c'est à dire une fois
qu'on a qu'on sort de l'école pour
devenir enseignant faire sa première
année dans les établissements et que
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
doit être revu complètement aujourd'hui
mais ça passe pas uniquement par le
salaire ça passe pas uniquement par le
salaire vous avez raison mais ça passe
aussi par le salaire je vais revenir sur
coup sûr une la tragédie qu qui est qui
a frappé samuel pâtit mais on voit à
quel point aujourd'hui
l'école n'est plus un sanctuaire et
combien les l'objet de toutes les
pressions y compris les pressions les
plus épouvantables et plus ignoble qui
ce sont celles là en l'espèce du
terrorisme islamiste mais devait être
enseignant est devenu un métier
incroyablement complexe ce que vous
transmettez est en concurrence avec ce
qu'il ya sur internet avec la façon dont
les parents eux décident de ce qui est
le bon enseignement la vérité ce qui
serait le mensonge
donc vous êtes dans une compétition à
laquelle les enseignants pas forcément
était préparé donc le métier
d'enseignant qui est celui de
transmettre à chaque enfant les savoirs
et donc de s'ouvrir à chaque enfant un
cerveau fermé d'enfants est un cerveau
d'où auquel vous ne pourrez pas
transmettre les clés l'état celle qui
lui permettra d'accéder à la liberté
conscience à l'épanouissement donc il
faut s'ouvrir le cerveau et et
l'attention des enfants et c'est un
métier de plus en plus difficile donc il
faut revoir le déroulement des carrières
revoir les salaires au revoir
l'attractivité de ce métier les temps de
formation tout au long de la vie et si
je peux me permettre
en finir avec cette obsession du
numérique notamment qui était celle de
monsieur blanc coeur je veux dire il
fait partie de ces ministre de
l'éducation qui dans le sillage d'un
certain nombre de parlementaires pensent
que le numérique peut tout régler
non moi je pense qu'il faut du il faut
des des profs des humains alors le
numérique peut aider on s'est vite vidé
dès dyslexie dyspraxie ça peut aider
mais aujourd'hui faut retrouver un
enseignement je vais dire
physique quoi sont centraux de supports
d'image on décide à un moment d'aller
chercher la tension en vis-à-vis parce
que à force de passer par toute sorte de
filtre de support je crois qu'on perd la
tension aussi des enfants est dans un
monde où je le rappelle ces gamins les
gamins français qui passe entre 3 heures
et 6 heures et demie par jour devant des
écrans sont atteints de troubles de la
concentration d'un prime de
développement du cerveau à cause du
temps passé dans les écrans il ya besoin
les mots semble-t-il de retrouver un
enseignement qui soit oui débarrassé de
tout pour partie en tout cas pas tout de
ces de tout cet environnement
technologique qui ne règle rien benoît
hamon l'autre actualité aujourd'hui
c'est l'assemblée nationale qui examine
la proposition de loi sécurité globale
ya notamment une mesure qui fait débat
c'est l'encadrement de la diffusion des
images de policiers et gendarmes qu est
ce que vous pensez de cette mesure
je suis contre je soutiens toutes celles
et ceux qui aujourd'hui disent que c'est
une grave erreur que d'aller sur ce
terrain là c'est une grave erreur
d'abord 30 rédaction
mais c'est pas par le dire c'est pas que
des rédactions de journaux qui seraient
des journaux très marqué à gauche très
vindicatif contre le gouvernement il ya
deux jours nous le
je vais prendre société la rédaction du
figaro a signé l'appel qui dit ce que
c'est une entrave à la liberté de la
presse
on peut pas les mêmes qui nous disent
garantissons la liberté d'expression
peuvent pas être ceux qui dessus
derrière le la tragédie que nous avons
connue avec samuel pâtit commence par
remettre en cause la liberté de la
presse qui est l'instrument par lequel
le citoyen est éclairée et peut forger
sa liberté de ton son avis sa conscience
politique
comment je fais moi comme citoyen pour
avoir un avis si la presse avec ses
règles sa déontologie et ben ne peux pas
me donner l'information n'y a pas besoin
de mieux protéger ses policiers et
gendarmes qui sont exposées notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux mais je veux
dire bien les agents de l'état d'une
manière générale
le temps en temps ça mais le réflexe et
on le connaît le réflexe qui est celui
de la place beauvau du ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est dès qu'il ya un problème de
sécurité c'est de restreindre les
libertés par nonce a toujours été comme
ça et tous les ministres de l'intérieur
vous le disent et les grands ministre de
l'intérieur sont ceux qui ont résisté à
cette tentation disant si vous voulez la
sécurité en réduisant les libertés vous
n'aurez ni la sécurité ni la liberté
c'est ce qui se passe pardon de le dire
mais ça fait maintenant 10 ans
qu'instruit par l'expérience
le gouvernement le quinquennat sarkozy a
réduit les libertés le quinquennat
hollande a réduit les libertés
avons-nous plus de sécurité non alors
évidemment à la fin on peut toujours
aller dans le sens de moins de liberté
mais ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'on
s'habitue à vivre sans la liberté et à
force nous nous préparons à d'état des
lendemains qui sont des lendemains
extrêmement dangereux qui peuvent être
des lendemains autoritaire la france
n'est pas à l'abri de trump ou ou de ou
de je ne sais quel avatar de trump c'est
à dire un régime autoritaire et vous
avez vu je le dise en 2017
quand ces gens là prennent le pouvoir
ils ont du mal à le quitter par les
urnes 1 est en tout cas ce que je dis
dans mes livres je vérifie aux états
unis alors peut-être que les
institutions américaines sont assez
fortes mais je ne suggère pas vu la
fragilité de nos institutions et du
paysage politique aux pays de tenter
l'expérience en france alors c'est la
tradition est toute trouvée on va parler
un petit peu de démocratie est ce que
vous vous étiez favorable au report des
régionales et départementales vous les
conclusions du rapport debré et est ce
que vous seriez favorable notamment vote
par correspondance l'autre sujet qui
agite les débats en ce moment j'écoute
et je crois que le rapport debré dit
régional en conjoint oui c'est vrai ces
sujets là parce que je suis pas non plus
super je suis plus l'excusé a priori
c'est ce verrou est votre parcours est
construit moi je suis favorable ce qui
permet et facilite l'exercice de la
démocratie malgré l'exemple américain
oui mais est-ce que le problème de
l'exemple américain c'est quoi c'est que
nous on a
bost qui marche très bien donc oui mais
moi je pense que c'est un problème de
postes non mais je pense que la poste
pays elle a parfois des défauts elle
avec un peu malmené des rôles aussi des
fois mais elle est bons résultats en ce
moment là voilà mes mots je pense que
voilà vive les facteurs font un dernier
mot et benoît hamon sur votre mouvement
je le disais vous aviez fonds des
générations vous disiez il peut pas y
avoir d'écologie sont socialistes de
socialisme sans écologie est ce
qu'aujourd'hui génération ça devient un
satellite d'europe écologie les verts
en tout cas ça a vocation à à construire
un pôle qui soient écologiques et
sociales moi je crois beaucoup à cette
idée je pense qu'il faut une armature
forte à la gauche et à l'écologie et que
autour d'europe ecologie-les verts mais
après j'ai exclu personne ni la france a
soumises d'une parti socialiste
d'ailleurs je les dis aux élections
présidentielles ça c'est simple il y
aura des gens qui sont candidats et puis
à des gens qui veulent être président de
la république et ceux qui veulent être
président de la république une condition
arabes unis eau qui rassemble l'écologie
et la gauche donc yannick jadot eric
piolle anne hidalgo gelin planche s'ils
font c'est exact là c'est pour démontrer
qu'ils veulent être présents la
république comme la seule condition pour
qu' il soit élu c'est qu'ils rassemblent
en famille il faut poser ces actes là
mais je avec j'ai donné des noms mais
moi je vous savez
je crois beaucoup aussi que ça pourrait
être
christiane taubira par exemple voilà il
ya des noms moi ils m'ont tous ces noms
m'intéresse je les ai déjà dit mais je
regarde ça d'un peu loin maintenant on
est en contact avec si je repars et il
me parle
mais voilà mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que voilà ils doivent tous faire
cette démonstration là et j'espère
qu'ils se mettront d'accord dans la
catégorie je veux être présidente a
accueilli vous avez déjà donné pour les
régionales on sent que vous me regardez
ça de loin puisque vous poser la
question sur la date mais ça vous ça
vous serez pas que ça vous chatouille
pas ça vous gratouille candidat aux
régionales ou à autre chose plus tard et
pour l'instant je veux dire je croise et
régionales sorte en ile de france vous
représenterez vous y retourner pour
l'instant et je sais pas je suis pas
dans cet état d'esprit êtes-vous vous
représenterez une région à l'erreur dans
cet état d'esprit mais ou non mais je je
je je dis oui j'ai une autre activité et
est encore faire des choses là bon bref
il faut quoi me reposer la question mais
non mais c'est pas ça c'est que heu je
profite dans le la cacophonie que que
j'observe un peu notamment sur les
chaînes info je vous mets à part je ne
voulais pas là dedans mais on a quand
même mais c'est nous c'est quand même de
venir je le dire bolloré
monsieur bolloré capitaines d'industrie
à la tête d'une télé d'extrême droite
est un de ceux bolloré qui est
aujourd'hui en train de mettre de
l'essence partout et d'allumer
tranquillement des feux partout avec
zemmour pro et compagnie donc cher je
moi je suis consterné de ce qui est en
train de de se passer je demande pas qui
est que les idées que je défends mais la
pensée dominante c'est celle de zemmour
et toute la ribambelle de nationalistes
belliqueux frustré plein de ressentiment
un plein d'aigreur qui aujourd'hui se
répand sur les réseaux sociaux sur les
chaînes info j'ai mixé news mais je veux
dire aujourd'hui on en trouve sur lci
une autre sur bfm en trouve partout
donc ça c'est la pensée dominante
zemmour c'est la pensée dominante
financé par les gros cachet de bolloré
bain
jour ses capitaines d'industrie pour
acquis rendre compte pour 1 qui rende
compte et on va terminer là dessus je
rappelle votre livre benoît hamon ce
qu'il faut de courage plaidoyer pour le
revenu universel
c'est aux éditions équateur merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous voir ce
matériau nos mamans et on fait ce titre
au club était éteint
[Musique]